we are now slowly getting to
the sports team,
um more up-to-date on sports topics, at least as we
talked about recently, but what you are
saying, there are now people who accuse
me of destroying Germany, I
made Scholz and Chancellor then
I got fazer in Nancy with my arm  I was
put in the stadium and we recommended to the German
team and all of their Goretzka
to keep quiet was
for the German elimination
you would have said that there are people
who gave us a poster because
that was already three lies in
one sentence
so they  The truth is I
didn't have or couldn't do it, but
there's a practical vote in the Bundestag and
we could only win one election, that
's the first, the second is with VW
I haven't spoken once to this day
and I haven't had any kind of
discussion about any
Action in Qatar or something like that, the
third thing is that I
actually have nothing to do with my mouth,
I was in the stadium, I saw her the
second she saw the world,
so of course we had that in
advance when working with the DFB
but then you actually
rejected it because you
actually took a shot at the one love bandage and
said that's the European
symbol with that we want to go and erm
we have
to get down as a service provider but that means the
DFB - well for him
Can you tell the workers a bit, well
before Qatar there was a lot of fuss
about how you act there, always in the
communicated, this bandage suddenly became
very relevant, it is perceived,
I think it is, I perceived it as a fan,
I have it  as a
communication service provider for the dfba
and of course I also
perceived it in an ideal way
and we pushed each other
up, I think everyone and the pressure on the
DFB in many places to
drive them into the corner he has to do
something now  what politics
is not able to do and that I found
it this whole discussion the absurd of
the discussion brings it to the
point when I see Robert three
four months before we
somehow kowtow to the uh Qataris where he
bows  before the Qataris that we will
hopefully get gas where we then
I think at Markus lands requires
that the national players should please
take a stand so he demands
something from professional footballers that he himself
as a politician
cannot implement doesn’t have the courage
whatever and I think that’s kind of the case
then it really stops I
think football has this
unifying power of football that you
are not against something but for something
so you recommended in the talks at the time
let’s just
play as normal here that we don’t
do anything here that’s normal  Do
n't bind gestures, nothing, well, there was
a campaign like that and um that was
already reported with just two asterisks, that's
why I can say that
there was a campaign, they
all go well too, you finally
decided against it because you said you
want to  participate in the Dutch idea of
this one love bandage the
European community idea, which is
actually totally correct that
you said you don’t want to
do national things on your own, you
want to set a common example in the European association with
many other nations
so and so  that then FIFA,
as dictatorships are common now,
practically or gladly do it, then at
the last second practically collect the thing
somehow and then we do
n’t play as the first nation, but
the English
and the English then do nothing, so
you have to understand that
the  DFB is then suddenly put in a
situation where he
may no longer
be able to do so much and when I then read that Axel
Springer Verlag somehow calls for
the courage trophy or something like that, the
pressure from the press
then on day 1 or the day before  put
unbelievable pressure on the game on the day of the game we
have to do something as a nation, you
footballers have to do something, dear DFB, you
have to do something
and then three weeks later you say something that
isn't too much politics
then I ask myself who
actually ran politics like that in many places
and I think we
all have to look in the mirror for ourselves
and see who did what wrong, who
drove whom where, who
harmed whom with which statements
and again I can't
bow to the Qataris on the one hand
then to sit on the secret couch
and say, now dear footballers, do
something, these are 18, 20, 25-year-old boys
who play football
and they were now the better
politicians, I think that we
enjoy it the most when we
convey our values  if we
also stand up for human rights
what the DFB does in an incredible
number of places what the Deusbären
does in an incredible number of places where an
incredible number of companies
can learn a lot from so and in this
situation we have to be, but we
still have to appreciate things and  At the
same time, sport must serve to promote
understanding between peoples, which means we
can also promote our values, it
doesn’t have to be one lovepine, it can
also be other things, it can be a
heart gesture, it can be action
for diversity, action against
racism and the like, so always  again also
the public reach
to use the platform to represent values, but
each individual player has to make that
up for themselves, you can’t say
the team has to do this and that now,
but
that has to
work more practically via gangs and it
has to be more of an invitation
to support such things but it must not
become a duty
Leonard Goretzka made such a gesture
in a
game against Hungary a few months ago
that was relatively attention-grabbing
it was
the euro so exactly one goal was scored
also a very important one if i
remember correctly there
is a homosexual legal situation
is also a bit problematic then rafael
brinkert who gives tips so to speak
and the situation 0.0 okay
that is 100  % Leon Goretzka, I
also think maybe two percent Thomas
Müller because these guys were sitting on the
bench and somehow saw the situation,
also with the fan block, they have
the discussion, they are mature players
and Leon is someone who
is incredibly political and
has a strong opinion  and that's not just
any agency, that's not just
me, that's 100% Leon Goretzka, and that's
why I really enjoy
sparring and
discussing those that are now, it's important for him to
advocate for justice  actually becoming a bit so go to the
ruhr area
for international understanding
and
things actually somehow relate to the topic of
religion and co. he also football clubs
than to believe in that is
the ease of the ruhr area and I
think we can all learn a lot from the
ruhr area